[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина, Галич,
Галицький національний парк]
Мисливство — це як наркотик, це як наркоманія.
Дехто стрибає з парашутом, і не може від цього відмовитись,
як він вже почав це робити.
Багато мисливців просто мають адреналін від полювання,
коли собаки шукають того звіра, коли вони знаходять, обгавкують того звіра,
коли мисливець підкрадається до звіра.
Це виділяється адреналін.
Колись, коли в мене батько був мисливцем,
[Володимир Бучко,
керівник центру реабілітації диких тварин]
і коли вже підходив час до полювання,
коли він мене брав на полювання — це було велике щастя,
я дуже тішився, що він бере мене на полювання.
Я радію тим тваринам: бачите це дике стадо?
Повністю до нас з мисливського господарства привезли дві олениці, вони були дикі.
Є великі шанси, що вони можуть жити в дикій природі.
І молоді, яких вони виховують, вже готова до життя у дикій природі
Це залежить від багатьох факторів: чи залишити полювання, чи надалі убивати.
Приходила неділя, коли чуєш постріли, що вже хтось полює, хтось вийшов у ліс.
Я думав, що можна просто вийти в ліс, погуляти там без зброї,
навіть не пробував — немає бажання.
Тобто я ходжу на дослідження, я ходжу з відеокамерою, я знімаю птахів,
роблю відеосюжети.
Але так, щоб пройтися десь із собакою — не можу, вже важко мені, вже трохи себе переборов.
Тобто зараз вже значно легше, я вже два роки не полюю.
Рівно два роки.
Ось та лисиця Аліса, це з неї все почалося. Їй дев'ять років.
Із маленького лисеняти вона у нас.
Просто добрі люди принесли лисеня, яке відібрали у мисливців.
Те лисеня мало використовуватись для притравлі мисливських собак,
і люди просто пошкодували, і віддали в Національний природній парк.
Зробили невеликий вольєр,
і вже настільки лисеня звикло до людей,
що можливості випустити в дику природу вже не було.
Довелося утримувати її постійно,
і відтоді вже почали нам зносити інших тварин:
покалічених, птахів.
І вже тоді в мене виникла ідея створення якби такого центру реабілітації.
Тут у нас сім'я ведмедів,
яка потрапила до нас із міста Херсон.
Там вона утримувалася в не дуже гарних умовах, у зоокуточку на Малому Потьомкінському острові.
І рівно рік тому ми змогли добудувати цей вольєр,
побудувати басейн, барлоги, хатинку, зробити збагачення,
тобто у вигляді різних гамаків таких, годівничок.
Тут вісім видів годівничок, де тварини самі собі корм дістають.
Все робиться для того, щоб тварина не сумувала,
щоб вона постійно брала корм із якихось таких складних місць.
Я завжди говорю херсонський ведмедик, тому що вони хоча і приїхали з Херсону в Галич,
вони не стануть ніколи галицькими,
назавжди лишаться херсонськими.
Тому що херсонці деякі дуже ображалися: «Чому від нас забрали ведмедів?»
Кажу: «Та не хвилюйтесь, вони залишаться вашими,
тільки будуть жити в Галичі в кращих умовах».
Центр, в принципі, створювався задля тварин,
а не заради людей, хоча певним чином центр відіграє функцію зоопарку:
сюди дуже багато приходить людей,
є нестача цього в нашому регіоні,
але, звичайно, ми більше уваги приділяємо екоосвіті.
Ми пояснюємо чому тут тварини, як вони сюди потрапили,
і в людини не повинно виникати якогось такого жалю до цієї тварини.
Більше виникає жаль у людини, яка потрапляє в зоопарк,
де тримають здорову дику тварину в тісній клітці.
Основне завдання нашого центру —
це створення настільки просторих, великих вольєрів,
щоб перебування тварин, було найбільш наближене до природніх.
Тут у нас живе вовчиця.
Татро, привіт!
Звір — ручний.
Нам передали були самця гарного, здорового.
Дикого.
То ми випустили в Карпати.
Настільки видно було, що звір — дикий,
і потім ми зробили розслідування,
і як з'ясувалося: його взагалі мисливець піймав у петлю,
і мав велике бажання отримати гарні гроші, на OLX продавав.
Приїхали до нього хлопці, культурно пояснили,
що не можна торгувати дикими тваринами.
Того вовка забрали, і відвезли в рівненський зоопарк.
А вже рівненський [зоопарк] до нас його переправив.
Як виявилося, звір був повністю дикий,
і ми його успішно випустили в дику природу.
А ця настільки ручна, що одного разу якісь «добродії» зробили дірку в вольєрі,
бо: «Ну як мучиться тварина, у вольєрі живе».
То вона вийшла, це була зима, видно було сліди,
вона вийшла з вольєру, походила по дорозі, і вернулася у вольєр.
Тобто настільки тварина ручна.
Так як цих, наприклад, рідкісних канюків степових, орланів —
це птахи повністю ручні, бачите?
Привіт!
Їх до нас рішенням суду передали зі Львова,
їх вилучили у фотографів у Львові, цих птахів.
Браконьєри спеціально лізуть у гнізда, забирають пташенят,
вчать їх сидіти на руці, потім використовують у туристичних місцях,
де масово збираються туристи для фотографій.
До речі, багато моїх колег зоологів, орнітологів залишились мисливцями.
Я в якийсь такий переломний момент перестав полювати.
Це є нормальна еволюція нормальної людини, нормального мисливця.
Хочеться в цьому житті зробити щось добре і корисне.
У всіх у нас багато гріхів, і деколи треба ті гріхи якось замолювати.
Доводиться робити щось корисне.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Максим Завалля]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Сценаристка
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Богдана Корогод]
[Музика
Sasha Boole]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]